Republicans sending mixed signals on the
budget john bolton joins the trump
administration and we do a tour of the
mailbag i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
so much to get to today a lot of news is
breaking the National Security Adviser
general McMaster HR McMaster is out John
Bolton the former ambassador to the UN
under the Bush administration is in the
budget is in complete flux we'll talk a
little about guns and we have the
mailbag plus a special interview with a
special guest a little bit later in the
program in the things I like segments
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Dollar Shave Club so
you need the comfort of a good shave not
only do you need the comfortable to
shave you need to smell good right you
need the shampoos you need the body
washes you need the toothpaste but you
don't really want to go to the market
and shop around for that kind of stuff
instead what you would be really
grateful for is just a box arriving at
your front door with all this stuff and
you never have to think about it again
well that's what Dollar Shave Club is
for it is more than just razors it is
better than shopping in a store Dollar
Shave Club delivers everything you need
to look smell and feel your best champ
Oh Body Wash toothpaste and of course
the best razors I have ever used
we in the Jewish community sometimes use
razors below the chin line but it's it
really is a fantastic straightedge I get
an amazing high-quality shave every
morning for my Dollar Shave Club
executive razor the true hero of any
morning routine of course is there dr.
Carver's shave butter which is
tremendous and ensures you don't get
that awful razor burn they also deliver
everything directly to you of course and
for this great experience all you have
to do is join Dollar Shave Club today
for just 5 bucks with free shipping you
get that six blade executive razor plus
trial sizes of shave butter body
cleanser and of course the fabled one
white but Charlie's at the butt wipes
then keep the blades coming for a few
bucks more per month get yours at
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben there's a
reason there's such a fast growing
company because their products are
awesome dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben
use that slash Ben so you get that
special deal again for five bucks you
get free shipping six six blade
executive razor and the trial sizes of
the shave butter the body cleanser and
the one way of Charlie's and then for a
few bucks more month that ensures that
you keep getting all of those things
arriving in your mailbox so it's just
great Dollar Shave Club common and use
the slash pens they know that we sent
you okay so we begin today with the
latest on the budget so the budget has
passed in the Senate the budget passed
in the Senate by a vote of 65 to 32 it
passed overwhelmingly in the House by
252 to 174 or something like that there
are a lot of Republicans we're very
unhappy with this budget I am among
those Republicans unhappy with this
budget I called it yesterday on the
program of crap sandwich that's because
every
bus is by definition a crap sandwich
it's why it's an omnibus the whole
purpose of an omnibus is to put a bunch
of stuff you like in there with a bunch
of stuff you don't and then say to folks
if you don't vote for this bill you're
voting against all the good things right
you're voting down all the goodies
yesterday we went through how the bill
doesn't cover anything for the border
wall essentially how it doesn't do
anything about daca how the how the bill
continues to ensure the Planned
Parenthood gets funded it doesn't remove
any of the Obamacare regulations there's
a bunch to really dislike about the bill
what's there to like about the bill is
that there is a a push in the bill for
greater military funding which of course
is necessary after the Obama years in
which we slashed our military pretty
dramatically so that is good but now
confusion is broken out so there are a
bunch of Republicans who of course were
very upset about this Ted Cruz was very
upset about this Mike Lee was very upset
about it
you know the Rand Paul was was quite
upset about the usual suspects in the
Senate who you would rely upon to be
upset about a budget-busting 1.3 billion
dot trillion dollar bill those people
were very upset about it predictably
enough but they weren't able to stop in
the Senate and rolls through with 65
votes
almost veto-proof majority so Trump
immediately comes out and says maybe he
will veto it what's weird about this of
course is that that's not what he's been
saying a day before so here's what he
tweeted tonight quote I am considering a
veto of the omnibus spending bill based
on the fact that the 800,000 Plus daca
recipients have not been totally
abandoned by the Democrats not even
mentioned in Bell and the border law
which is desperately needed for our
national defense is not fully funded so
a few things about the suite number one
it's fascinating that he's saying that
he wants to veto the omnibus spending
bill based on the fact that daca isn't
taken care of the deck wasn't solved so
several times in three separate times
there was an attempt to make a deal
during this bill negotiation with regard
to data and the what the Trump
administration offered was and what Paul
Ryan offered was three years of
continuation of daca people could still
sign up as dreamers for daca three years
of continuation of daca but not final
status negotiations on the people who
are actually here you know it's not a
pathway to citizenship for them they
just could stay here for three more
years for three years of wall funding
and the Democrats turned that one down
flat they instead suggested that they
wanted full legalization of 1.8 million
illegal immigrants well Trump had
already basically offered that right
like a few weeks ago he offered twenty
five billion dollars in Wall funding
plus n-2 chain migration and a few other
goodies in exchange for legalizing 1.8
million dreamers Nathan weren't able to
come to an agreement and now Trump is
saying the Democrats walked away from
the table there is some truth to that
but he has a Republican majority so why
isn't the border wall just being funded
why isn't the border wall just being
funded if the border wall funding were
in there there's no question it passes
the house right Trump's able to stump up
enough support that he gets that through
and it's weird to me that Republicans
aren't passing it it's also weird to me
that that Trump is now threatening to
veto considering that 24 hours ago he
was saying the reverse here's what
here's what from tweeted yesterday quote
got 1.6 billion to start while and
southern border rest will be forthcoming
most importantly that 700 billion to
rebuild our military 716 billion next
year most ever had to waste money on Tim
giveaways in order to take care of
military pay increase a new equipment a
couple things one military pay increase
already went into effect I think a
couple months ago but beyond that this
is a very Pro omnibus package tweet all
right this is Trump saying I like the
omnibus package we even got a little bit
of wall funding well number one Mexico
ain't paying for the wall gang and this
is gonna be up to Trump and the
Republicans to do it but it's it's
fascinating to see how Trump flipped on
this and his own bill right within 24
hours literally yesterday Mick Mulvaney
his head of Office of Management and
Budget he came out and he said listen
Trump isn't gonna veto this we may not
like the bill very much but Trump isn't
gonna veto and so here's what Mulvaney
had to say let's cut right to the chase
is the president going to sign the bill
the answer is yes why because it funds
his priorities we've talked for the last
I don't know three four five six months
about trying to get the president's
priorities funded and this omnibus bill
does that so all things considered when
we look at the bill we have to weigh
what we asked for and what we had to
give away to give it is it perfect
no is it exactly what we asked for in
the budget no were we ever going to get
that no that's not how the process works
it's a weird strategy which suggests
it's not strategic why is it a weird
strategy because if you were going to
threaten to veto something wouldn't you
do it before the Republicans vote for it
so you get your entire party on record
voting for a bill you then threaten to
veto what like how is that even logical
how does that make any sort of political
sense now
if Trump actually did veto it it would
be a sign that maybe Trump actually
wants to get involved in the
policy-making process but it also means
that it's very difficult for anybody to
know what he's going to do Trump always
says that he wants to be unpredictable
with regard to his enemies well you
can't be unpredictable with regard with
regard to your allies put aside the fact
that he's right that the bills bad the
question is why didn't you say this a
week ago
why didn't throw he go to Mitch
McConnell and Paul Ryan say listen I
don't like this bill I'm gonna veto it
if you pass it so to make some changes
why didn't he throw his weight on the
side of the house freedom caucus and how
is it helpful for him to jump in late
when opinion turns against the bill and
then take the legs out from underneath
his own party if you're Paul Ryan you're
Mitch McConnell and you're sitting
around going listen we went to the White
House we updated them every step on this
negotiation and they said fine and now
they're killing us hey how do you trust
the President to have your back if the
president doesn't have your back
it is a serious problem for Republicans
in Congress now again it's a separate
issue from whether Trump is right about
the bill the bill sucks he's right today
he was wrong yesterday hey the bill is
not good the bill should not have passed
the bill should have been pared down
Republicans need to do better and this
is what the freedom caucus is there for
in the house they do a great job trying
to push back against some of these
spending priorities and then hopefully
get a few concessions on the way one
other note about the budget before we
move on
everybody's always worried about the
amount of spending in the budget oh 1.3
trillion dollars in 150 billion dollar
increase in non-defense discretionary
spending and all the rest that is not
what's bankrupting the country hey the
non-defense discretionary spending is
bad I hate it it's my tax dollars and I
am paying an awful lot of money to the
federal government and taxes but that is
not actually what is creating our
deficits what is creating our deficits
are Medicaid Medicare and Social
Security those are the things that are
driving our deficits these structural
entitlement programs we are spending
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
on trillions of dollars but it's two
dudes literally two thirds of the
federal budget that stuff is not even
discretionary right that's written into
law it's mandatory spending when there's
a government shutdown people still get
their Social Security checks so that's
what needs to be restructured so you
know if it were if they give over the
case that we're trading this omnibus
package in favor of an entitlement
reform like Paul Ryan says listen I just
want to title that reform will pass this
budget so we don't have to spend our
political capital here but entitlement
reforms next on the docket I'd make that
trade in a heartbeat
and that is not the trade that's being
made the reason people are upset is
because they feel like Republicans
promised for years and years and years
that they care about the spending and
it's pretty obvious that Republicans do
not in fact care deeply about the
spending okay so another big
administration news the National
Security Adviser
a chart McMaster is out this has been
rumored for legitimately half a year one
of the things that was really funny is
that last week Trump tweeted out that HR
McMaster was completely securing his job
he also tweeted out that one of his
lawyers a guy named John Dowd was
completely secure in his job and then
that guy left the media had reported
both of them were on the outs Trump of
course has fake news it turns out that
was not fake news because when Trump
says fake news it's only fake news like
40% of the time well the guy who is
replacing HR McMaster McMaster was sort
of a foreign policy policy establishment
guy he's somebody who believed in sort
of real politique balance of power he
tended to be relatively a kind of
weirdly interventionist in certain areas
and non-interventionist another he was
he had kind of a squishy view of the
Iran deal
John Bolton's views are extraordinarily
clear John Bolton is the person who I'd
wanted for Secretary of State I think
he'd be better in that role than his NSA
but I'm happy to have him inside the
administration Bolton of course was
ambassador to the UN under george w bush
he is not a neocon and people have said
that he's in neocon he is not to define
neocon they're really two definitions of
neocon definition number one is the
historical definition which is somebody
who is a lefty during the 1960s and then
realized the errors of their ways they
were in the in the popular phrase mugged
by reality and became more conservative
it was a specific movement of very
heavily Jewish people in the 1960s like
urban crystal and and Daniel Bell who's
not Jewish was a member of these these
were the neo cons in the 1970s the
people had shifted over to the other
side Bolton was always a conservative so
from by that definition he's not a
neocon the other definition that's used
is about people like Paul Wolfowitz who
are very into nation-building the idea
that we're supposed to go into a rock
knock over Saddam and then stay there
and build up the nation that was
actually not something that Bolton
suggested doing he said we had to get
rid of Saddam because Saddam was funding
terrorism and pursuing weapons of mass
destruction according to every
Intelligence Agency on earth but that
doesn't mean that we shouldn't have
turned the country back over to the
Iraqis as soon as humanly possible
instead of sticking around and pouring
hundreds of thousands of more troops in
there so he's been called a
nation-building neocon for a while and
that's not true he was he wasn't in
favor of the Arab Spring for his
Apple he's not averse to leaving
American allies who happen to be
dictators in power he was in favor of
leaving Hosny Mubarak and power in Egypt
so he is not a democracy first neocon in
that sense so people are
mischaracterizing in the situation
democrats of course are going nuts over
this Chris Matthews I don't know they
say the jump button got you just leave
that mustache that jump boat now get
over here rub my hair suits on wrinkled
he's rolling here a good show jump book
that guy even has a mustache though okay
I said my wife Kathleen you even like
mustache she said no MSNBC how about go
mr. Hawkes because he promised a working
men and women of those states that voted
for him the gritty factory workers and
other people who didn't like these worse
because their kids do all the fighting
and getting killed and losing their legs
and everything else he said to them no
more stupid Wars now he brings in the
godfather of stupid Wars john bolton
anyway the congressman has been with us
thank you so much Eric so of California
he's got by they stupid wise John but
who's John buttons Paul jumbles like
Under Secretary of State for Near East
affairs or something like at the time so
again the idea that john bolton was the
architect of the iraq war is just not
true it is not true he was in favor of a
broader Syrian intervention I want to go
through John Bolton's record a little
bit and and in a minute I'm gonna go
through his record and rather fulsome
fashion will discuss what his actual
views are and how they will impact the
administration whether we should be
worried about him but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
Tommy John so spring has sprung which
means it is time for a little spring
cleaning which means go into your
underwear drawer take out all the
underwear that have the holes in them
and the elastic that no longer holds up
take them throw them in the garbage and
now go get the mind-blowing comfort of
Tommy John hey Tommy John is committed
to providing unparalleled comfort not
only in their undergarments but in all
of their incredible apparel so first of
all their underwear are just tremendous
I mean the design on the underwear is
the best underwear on the market and
these things last I mean you put them in
the wash over and over and over and it
is totally fine they come out basically
the same as they went in it's the best
pair you will ever wear or it's free and
they have that as a guarantee if it's
not the most comfortable underwear your
that I have ever worn or you have ever
worn then Tommy John will foot the bill
for the underwear and they make socks
that stay up all day undershirts that
never come untucked reimagine t-shirts
Tommy John has all of these things so
check it out and right now if you go to
Tommy John calm slash up here you get
20% off
your first order that Tommy John calm
slash capiro for 20% off the most
comfortable clothing items imaginable
Tommy John comm / Shapiro you know the
the underwear eliminates bunching it
eliminates the the riding up it's it's
designed in in a different way hey I
don't want to give away all the secrets
of the time we draw on underwear because
it gets into uncomfortable territory for
listeners but let me just tell you that
Tommy John is Tommy John's underwear are
unparalleled in their comfort and their
ease so check it out over at Tommy John
comm /up hero 20% off your first order
try it and again it's not the best pair
you've ever worn it's free so Tommy
John's comm slash apparel 20% off the
most comfortable clothing items that you
will ever wear Tommy John comm slash
appear again use that slash apparel so
they know that we say ok so what exactly
is John Bolton's actual record so here's
an editorial that he wrote in 2012 about
the situation in Syria what he said was
as hostilities in Syria roll on unabated
the civilian casualties rise because of
combat operations in urban areas and
execution-style killings in response
calls for US military intervention of
one sort or another continue to aid the
opposition increase while the Obama
administration did there's over whether
to continue relying on the UN Security
Council and former UN Secretary General
Kofi Annan but what our America's
interests at stake and what is the best
way to protect them although it is easy
to concentrate on the stomach churning
in television images we should operate
on the basis of strategy not emotion
that doesn't mean doing nothing but
neither doesn't mean knee-jerk reactions
instead of careful analysis he says that
regime change in Syria is prima facie in
America's best interest as well as the
interests of Israel and our Arab friends
in the region who see nothing but danger
for themselves if Iran's hegemonic
ambitions unfold successfully he says
there's no reason to
kado Assad he says that we should have
supported the Syrian opposition
he says the possibility of getting rid
of Assad is is is now more remote given
the widespread infiltration of the
anti-assad forces by al Qaeda and other
terrorists in truth we don't know enough
about the opposition's political or
military leadership to predict who would
prevail in the immediate aftermath of
Assad's overthrow this is john bolton
writing about syria in 2012 in such
circumstances the risk of a radical
Islamist replacing Assad is considerably
higher than it would have been if we had
moved to Houston years ago a relatively
orderly exit by Assad is one thing a
disorderly indeed chaotic accent is
quite another especially given the risk
that Syria's chemical and biological
Bin's assets and maybe the nuclear
assets might fall into the hands of
people even worse than Assad and then he
talks about the humanitarian
considerations he says without
substantial on the ground troop presence
we cannot prevent all of that brutality
and evil so he sort of evaluates the
whole situation and and he says his
bottom line is Obama's not up to the job
in Syria the gravest risk of American
involvement is that his administration
in Iran might find common ground in the
Middle East chess game Iran would allow
Assad to fall losing its pawn and it's
change Obama would agree to do even less
than he's doing now to stop Iran's
nuclear weapons program so he says we
should cut Syria off from its major
supporters here's his actual program cut
Syria off from its major supporters
Russia should be told in no uncertain
terms that can forget about sustained
good relations with the United States as
long as it continues to back Assad we
should resume full-scale indeed
accelerated efforts to construct limited
missile defense system to font and
designed by George W Bush to protect
America's territory against Russia and
other rogue states he says we should
announce our withdrawal from the new
start arms control treaty and then we
should tell Iran then our patience with
their decade-long ploy of using
diplomacy to gain time to advance their
nuclear weapons program has ended Tehran
should face a stark choice and we can
leave to their imagination what will
happen if they fail immediately to
dismantle all aspects of their existing
nuclear effort and we should also
reverse the fantasy that despite its
repeated violation of the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty that Iran is
entitled to a peaceful nuclear program
then he says finally in Syria itself we
should do now what we have begun to do
ten years ago find Syrian rebel leaders
who are truly secular and who opposed
radical Islam will disavow al Qaeda
Hezbollah and other terrorist groups and
who will reject Russian and Iranian
hegemony over their country we'll need
some reason to believe the opposition
can prevail against Assad so this is not
a guy who's saying let's go in and knock
over Assad willy-nilly right this is a
guy who's actually taking into account
the situation on the ground in Syria and
taking a pretty anti-russian perspective
right for all the people on the Left who
are claiming that Trump is in thrall to
the Russians John Bolton certainly is
not in thrall to the Russians in fact I
have the evidence that John Bolton is
not in thrall to the Russians here's
what John Bolton had to say about
Russian sanctions just a few months ago
this in December 2016 Russians have
walked all over the Obama administration
for eight years it's really been a
pathetic performance so what this last
burst of activity has to do is hard to
say I do think it's intended to try and
box the Trump administrator
I think it will fail this is simply an
executive order president Trump decides
to reverse it it's easy enough to do if
you make them feel pain and others feel
pain then the possibility of deterring
future conduct like this increases
that's what we need to do okay so
obviously john bolton is not a pansy for
russia right and there's a guy who's
very very harsh on russia he's also very
harsh on iran
he's very harsh on syria now people have
said that he's a war monger what's
hilarious about this is that he's been
in favor of a lot of the same wars
Democrats were in favor of right Libya
was actually Hillary Clinton's war now
what what he said what Boulton said
about Libya is that we should ask
Qadhafi I think that he was wrong about
that right he had said this back in 2011
I believe that we should kill Muammar
Qaddafi as in March 2011 he said that he
said there was a risk of terrorist
takeover he says one of the things the
administration should be doing is
identifying pro-american pro-western
leaders in the opposition and assisting
them I don't see any evidence there
doing that now but this is a rare case
of a Qaddafi on the one hand the unknown
on the other I'd picked the unknown
obviously that was wrong you shouldn't
pick the unknown you should pick what
what you know unfortunately but you know
the again the idea that Bolton is some
sort of wild cowboy who's out there
stumping for war in all cases is is not
correct here is what Bolton had to say
about the Iran deal so Trump's entire
national security team now right he's
got a Mike Pompeo over at state and it's
got Bolton as NSA all of them are anti
Ron deal which is a good thing as the
Iran deal is a debacle and a disaster
here's Bolton just a few years ago
talking about the stupidity and evils of
the Iran deal but let's let's be clear
what America's interest is this deal was
a strategic debacle not only is it bad
for the United States in the big picture
the terms of the deal are bad you can't
hold them to the terms of a deal that
are is amorphous and unclear and subject
to multiple interpretations as this deal
is I think the only thing that we can do
to try and get back on the right track
is to say the deal is over I am
confident Iran was violating it before
the ink was dry they're doing it still
today and you know unless you're content
to have Iran on an unimpeded path to
deliverable nuclear weapons this deal
has to be scrapped because there's no
question that he's a hawk but he's also
not in neocon in the sense of
nation-building Bolton has defended the
war in Iraq here's what he said
years ago I believe this 2009 talking
about the Lorna Rock and why it was
justified were we right to go to war I
don't think there's any question that
the decision to overthrow Saddam Hussein
was the correct decision I think you
have to look at what happened in Iraq
through the prism of two separate
questions was the initial decision
correct and was what happened
subsequently the way we wanted it to be
the answer the first question to me
despite the events of the six years
after the invasion is still
unquestionable yes the regime itself
Saddam Hussein his bath party were
threats to peace and security in the
region and the larger world okay so a
lot of people I'm left very upset about
that because it's become conventional
wisdom to say that the Iraq war was
wrong
based on the evidence that we had at the
time the Iraq war is not wrong the
pursuit of how we did the Iraq war was
wrong wrong in the end members of the
Bush administration have acknowledged as
much again you can only go to war based
on the evidence that you have in front
of you
Bill Clinton Hillary Clinton Al Gore
John Kerry every Democrat Nancy Pelosi
all of them supported the Iraq war
because the evidence that was put in
front of them was very different from
the evidence that was later gathered now
the real reason that people are upset
about Boulton in the in the NSA position
is because they are afraid that he's
such a hawk I'll go to trump he'll talk
about your hawk or into Trump's here and
suddenly we'll be at war and the reason
they're saying this is because Bolton
has been particularly harsh on North
Korea so he just wrote an op-ed for The
Wall Street Journal in February 20 and
February 8 2018 so not even a month ago
in which he talked about the legal case
for striking North Korea first right he
talked about preemption and what he said
is this preemption opponents argue
action is not justified because
Pyongyang does not constitute an
imminent threat they are wrong
the threat is imminent and the case
against preemption rests on a
misinterpretation of a standard that
derives from pre nuclear pre ballistic
missile x given the gaps in US
intelligence about North Korea we should
not wait until the very last minute
they'll risk striking after the North
has deliverable nuclear weapons a much
more dangerous situations he's not
actually making the case for preemptive
strike he is saying that it is legal
he's saying this is how we should think
about the threat of nuclear warheads
delivered by ballistic missiles in 1837
Britain unleashed pre-emptive fire and
fury against a wooden steamboat it is
perfectly legitimate for the United
States to responds the current necessity
posed by North Korea's nuke
weapons by striking first now so I think
Bolton's gonna walk into that office and
say to trump let's attack North Korea I
do not I don't think that's who bolton
is yeah I've met John Bolton several
times I do not think that ambassador
Bolton will now and I say Bolton is a
guy who is going to pander to Trump's
worst instincts in terms of hitting
buttons that fire missiles I think that
he knows he's now part of an
administration where the guy at the top
is not supremely stable with regard to
the use of force for example and I think
that knowing that he is going to be
pretty careful about what he says to the
president the good news is the president
trusts Bolton the president trusts
Pompeo the president trusts mattis and
three of them I think make a much better
team than HR McMaster Rex Tillerson in
Madison that's a-that's there's no
question that's a better team overall in
terms of a conservative foreign policy a
bush Ian but non neoconservative foreign
policy which i think is more realistic
but not paleo conservative the Trump
campaign is a paleo con he is not a
paleo Khan and and his team proves it
okay so I want to get to two guns I want
to get to a little bit of a foreign
policy and I wanna get to the mailbag
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Jen you sell so Jen you
sell is actually one of my oldest
advertisers okay Jen you sell these are
folks who were advertising with me long
ago and I was doing a radio show in
Seattle I love these guys because their
product is great my wife particularly
loves that they are an advertiser on the
show now because she's getting their
products again and their products are
just fantastic okay what they do is they
get rid of all the bags under your eyes
to go to the bags and the puffiness
they're a problem for millions of men
and American American men and women but
they have something called Gen you sell
rights Gen you sell from shamon e okay
they have plant stem cell technology and
people are saying things like this
here's a letter they've received from
from Susan I've been using Jenny sell
for a couple of months the puffiness
around my eyes is going on even the
crow's feet small lines you've
disappeared they haven't come back I
love your product I use it under my eyes
around my cheekbones on my eyelids it's
not just Susan folks okay my wife has
been using it my mom steals the stuff
away she comes over to the house and if
my wife leaves it out my mom just takes
it home
whose is it everybody loves the results
that they are getting with Jen you saw
with it's instant effects you will see
results in the first 12 hours or you get
your money back
right that is the guarantee order now
and get the Jen you sell collagen
builder and deep firming serum two best
sellers also free call 866 329 o for 866
329 o for again then 2 800 663 2904
go to genu Cellcom that's GE and you CEO
calm Jen you sell dot-com you call now
Express shipping is also free Jen you
sell calm against Jen you sell calm and
the number is 866 3 2904 as i say my
mom's been using the products for years
my wife is excited that we're getting
their products again Jen yourself from
Xiamen each Eket out it will help with
all the bags and puffiness around your
eyes it's great for women it's also good
for guys I mean if you're not getting
enough sleep like I am then this is a
really useful useful product ok so I
just want to do a quick note here on
guns and then I want to get to the mail
bags I would like to have some real time
to explore the mail bag with you today
so first I'm gonna time magazine has put
up a new cover its new cover is is all
the kids who are anti-gun from parkland
and that is not what the cover looks
like it net is what the cover looks like
there we go so the it's the only kids
who get to make the time cover are the
kids who hate guns
right it's David hog and I'm a Gonzales
and Cameron kasky and all of them posing
in very dramatic fashion and then it
says enough across the front now I don't
know what one of them is not wearing
shoes that's weird but besides that I'm
just wondering why it is that only a
certain number these kids get on the
cover right Kyle cash if we've talked
about on the show before and who I've
mentored a little bit hey there's no
reason why he shouldn't be on the cover
there he's a student there he's been
extraordinarily vocal and he's been much
more useful in the gun debate than any
of these kids right Kyle has actually
been going around meeting with
legislators to talk about the Stop gun
violence act right he's he's been
working on that with legislators these
kids are just going on TV and jabbering
to Ellen like if they I understand the
experienced tragedy they're entitled to
their perspective but the only
perspective the media wants you to hear
is their perspective and the perspective
of people like David hog I'm sorry his
perspective on guns is just not that
valuable he doesn't have anything to say
that has any merit to it here's an
interview that was done with him
yesterday it is not good ok this is
David hog jabbering on about the NRA
they're pathetic cuz I want to keep
killing our children
they could have blood from children
spattered all over their faces and they
wouldn't take action because they all
still see those dollar signs just makes
me think what's there out there that
want to continue to sell more guns
murder more children and honor so just
get reelected
where what type of person are you when
you want to see more money than
children's lives I mean it's disgusting
I mean he's been heated repeating
crap over and over and over it's
disgusting what he's saying it's it's
ridiculous but these are the people that
the media choose to focus on which is of
course that makes perfect sense because
these are the people pushing the media's
agenda okay so now I want to do
something special today and I think we
may change the format of the show in
order to do this I learned you the
mailbag earlier today so that all of our
friends who watch over at Facebook live
and watch YouTube live that they can
they can check this out right now by
watching the mailbag
if you want to subscribe by the way you
can be part of the mailbag so if you
wanna subscribe right now then you get
your questions answered we will answer
your questions live early on the show
today so let's just jump right in John
says what's up Benjamin my dude I'm a
high school student competing in a
homeschool Christian debate League our
lincoln-douglas resolution is
nationalism ought to be valued above
globalism nationalism has been a
difficult side for me to argue because I
can't seem to find a moral reason
nations should value it just a practical
one since this is a hot topic nowadays
is there any moral reason nations should
value nationalism well sure I think
there are two arguments in favor of
nationalism and then there's a bad
argument that people use for nationalism
so here are the two good arguments in
favor of nationalism the first one is
that nationalism isn't nationalism its
patriotism what you are defending about
the United States why America is a great
place is because America has a special
Creed and that Creed ought to be
defended
so I'll defend American nationalism but
I'm not as interested in the nationalism
of Nations that have crappy founding
principles I don't really care about
their nationalism because why would I
why would I find that particularly
convincing our founding principles are
good their founding principles suck
therefore America's nationalism is a
good thing because a stronger America in
the world is a better thing for the
world and for the citizens of the United
States and that's argument number one is
the principles upon which a country is
founded should be the basis for
nationalism which means patriotism over
nationalism right now globalism not
nationalism patriotism okay the second
argument is one that was made in the
Federalist Papers that we talked about a
few weeks back and that is that there is
a natural drive for people to feel a
kinship with the people that they occupy
a country with that people do feel you
know for better or worse they do feel
ethnic kinship they do feel familial
kinship they do feel cultural kinship
they do feel that if you share a
religion with somebody these are all
these are all things that you share and
nationalism helps congeal all of that
into a fighting force on behalf of tribe
now this can devolve really quickly into
a romantic nationalism that's really
nasty and terrible I'm not in favor
that romantic nationalism that's why I
don't buy into the these sort of
ethno-nationalism you hear from the
alt-right it's why I have a hard time
with some of the far-right movements in
Europe let's say we're nationalists but
we can't explain to you why we're
nationalists we just know that France
has to be defended but we have no
central principles upon which France is
base that we're trying to defend but I
think the way to defend nationalism is
to say that the nation-state is a useful
tool in the promulgation of good ideas
it's also a useful tool in the
promulgation of really bad ideas so the
case for nationalism is good nationalism
nationalism on behalf of countries that
have good ideas as like I don't care
about Saudi Arabia nationalism per se I
care a lot about American nationalism I
care much more about British nationalism
for example because it connects to an
Anglo American heritage and it same I
care about French nationalism a lot more
than I care about Libyan nationalism for
example and that's not being me being
racist or ethnocentric it's the opposite
it's me saying that you and your friends
look alike any wanna nation that's not a
good enough reason for you to have a
nation it's more important to actually
have some centralizing principles
globalism by contrast basically says
that we should treat all of these
perspectives as equal and we should
never privilege our own perspective over
that of anyone else so if I had to rank
these things in order of usefulness
importance and and worth I would say
patriotism and nationalism globalism
okay an says most of my reading these
days is done via audio books is there
any chance you'll read your upcoming
books thanks and so I was asked to do my
last novel but because it was a novel I
felt like it would be weird for me to do
it because I can't act at all maybe my
next non-fiction book so maybe that
maybe the book that I'm writing right
now on the history of Western philosophy
I'll read that one I think a v-notch
says hey Ben is there one classical
composer that you absolutely hate well
there are some that I think just our
tedious is all as all get-out like
there's some people like Bruckner I
think the Bruckner is just yeah I'm not
a fan there there are some modern
classical composers who I am NOT a fan
of you know obviously Cage Philip Glass
these are people who I don't really like
very much but as far as older classical
composers they're there a lot of people
are very fun of Mahler I just find that
it's sections of beauty in meshed in in
long swaths of boring vogner needed an
editor with an axe as he has these
incredible moments of uplift but every
opera is 18 hours long
and filled with fat people singing at
each other so I'm not I'm not a huge
vogner fan um yeah I do rank them
differently obviously like I like but
list is fun to listen to but he I don't
find him particularly deep but I'm very
much with like but if I have to name the
top four it's the same as everybody else
is presumably and it's not in this order
necessarily it's Beethoven Brahms Bach
Mozart right beyond that Mendelssohn is
great there's some Sun songs that's
great Bartok is great
the ones who suck you really haven't
heard of write ones you got replayed on
radio over and over are usually the ones
who are who are pretty good nathaniel
says I watched your speech susquehanna I
thought it was hands-down one of the
best and most linguistically precise
speeches of your career my question is
this in the Q&A you debated the head of
the College Democrats and cited some
very specific studies how much of that
was from Emory how much time you spend
preparing stats and information before a
given speech or debate well I spent my
entire career in mesh getting stats and
statistics and reading right the other
earlier this week for example I did a
15-minute segment maybe a 20-minute
segment on one specific study that was
cited in high profile by the New York
Times I spent a lot of time reading
those studies because I want to know
them right if I'm if I don't have the
data right I'm happy to be reappraising
that's like for example I in some of the
speeches in the last couple of years I
mistakenly said the transgender suicide
rate was 45 percent what I meant to say
and this is just a slip of the tongue I
actually knew this was that the
transgender suicide attempt rate was 45%
obviously the suicide rates not 45
percent or in five years everybody be
dead right that's not how it works but
when people correct me on stats I'm
happy to be corrected on them the UCLA
the conversation I had with the guy at
Susquehanna he was quoting from the same
study that I had already cited because
I'd read that study I knew the study he
cited some other studies I've studied a
lot on this particular issue because
it's so controversial and again I'm
always happy to look at new studies in
order to in order to make my my
arguments better or stronger or change
them or maybe shift my perspective on
things I try to follow the data as much
as possible when it comes to political
arguments one more and then we'll have
to the Facebook sign off so if Lori says
hi Ben what are your thoughts on the
personal usefulness of social media
especially among children and teenagers
do you think there's any aspect truly
worthwhile even if people are permitted
to do what they like legally online when
will you let your children use social
media sites like Facebook or Instagram
many thanks for your good fight Laurie
um I'm not sure I'm ever gonna let my
kids use face
honestly I think that Instagram same
thing Twitter I uses a news following
you know thing I think kids will want to
use social media but I have real doubts
whether it's good for kids to use social
media I think that the the best-case
scenario is that they feel some sort of
vague kinship with people they go to
school with and the worst case scenario
is that they get bullied mercilessly and
receive a bunch of bad messages on
social media so I'm not gonna I don't
plan on letting my daughter get a
Facebook account sigh that just I don't
speaking of which time for a Facebook
sign-off so if you want to listen to the
rest of the show if you want to watch
the rest of the show live you want to
ask a question right now because we'll
take live questions right now go over to
daily wire.com and subscribe for $9.99 a
month you can get the subscription my
show live Clemens show live Knowles the
show live be part of the mailbag like
subscribe now as I'm talking and before
you know it you will be asking me a
question I will be answering it for you
so go check that out right now annual
subscription comes with this the very
greatest in all beverage vessels left
dissed year's hot or cold tumbler ooh
ahh magical so you get all of that with
the annual subscription if you want to
listen free for later lid then go over
to SoundCloud go to iTunes go to youtube
please subscribe please leave us a
review again when it comes to the
subscriptions guys you get all that good
stuff plus you're helping us out I mean
let's be frank about this we all need
your help especially with the social
media crackdown on so many conservative
companies and so if you really like what
we do help us out by subscribing it
really is something that I'm personally
very grateful for so go check us out
over there we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
so Robert asks what is my least favorite
historical myth we're continuing with a
mailbag here Robert asks what is my
least favorite historical myth um well I
think that leftists revisionist history
about America's Founding is probably my
least favorite historical myth they've
create an entire mythical history of
America in which America is a garbage
place filled with racism and inherently
unchangeable right it's built into our
DNA as Barack Obama liked to say some of
the other myths that I dislike I'd have
to go back and investigate some of the
ancient myths they're fun to read I mean
if you go back and read Greek mythology
it's it is fun to read I'm not sure
there's a whole lot of moral value in
those myths because it's pagan and one
of the problems with a lot of the pagan
myths is that they are supposed to
reinforce the the chaotic nature of the
world right the reason that paganism was
paganism and it's not completely
illogical is because people looked at
the world they said this is a chaotic
place it must be reflect the fact that
there is chaos and in Rome beyond that
is manipulating the cast that is
happening here this is where
judeo-christianity changes everything
judaism changes everything by saying no
there is a master plan to all of this
and all the stuff that looks like chaos
see you may not actually be chaos in the
eyes of the person who made the in the
eyes of the person not meaning human
being but in the eyes of the being who
designed the system daniel says what are
your biggest qualms with
anarcho-capitalism my biggest qualms the
anarcho-capitalism
really are just lack of understanding
about how law enforcement needs to work
for example so the argument for
anarcho-capitalism is that you'll just
have roving bands of people who hire
each other for for protection and
everything will go fine I think you do
need a basic gridlock of a basic
framework rather of laws that guarantee
for example possession of private
property to be protected by a police
force that is applicable to everybody
because otherwise private property is
not a just central concept you know all
the bases of capitalism require somebody
to protect those bases Blake says hey
Ben do you think a conservative can
become governor here in California maybe
I'm actually not completely I don't mean
it's completely impossible I think it's
difficult obviously and I think that you
have to have a conservative who actually
runs on crime I can't have a
conservative running on education like
Schwarzenegger or like my friend Tom
double-car oh you can't have people you
Tom hasn't actually run for governor I
mean it who was it ran for governor the
other
goodness gracious I told him over and
over a Neel Kashkari when you'll crush
car he ran for governor here in
California I kept telling him why are
you not running on crime he said no I
want to run on education I said then you
will lose and lose really badly which
indeed he did you know I think that it I
think that it is meant that maybe that
would happen anyway but the only time
Republicans win in blue areas when they
talk about crime I Rudy Giuliani Richard
Riordan here in Los Angeles that's when
you get a Republican winning is is when
they talk about crime and and quality of
life issues let's see Laurie well as
hade law reads question right okay Neil
he says hi been here in Ireland the
student visa to USA and a we overstate
is seen as a rite of passage many Irish
go on to become undocumented illegal
workers in the US but maintain a strong
passion and love for life out there
ovary patties week are our prime
minister okay was visiting and proposing
and proposing solutions to this with one
scheme being put forward as the new
scheme would see new visa benefits and
protections for Americans in Ireland in
return for them doing something similar
for the undocumented Irish in the United
States having lived and worked in both
countries there's a lot of Yanks who are
eager to come across the Atlantic how
would you feel about a nation by nation
solution to illegal immigration as well
as the above it in particular I mean I'm
in favor of a person-by-person solution
to illegal immigration not even in a
nation by nation one I'm not sure that
we should be doing foreign exchange
programs with with Ireland but I do
think that if there's somebody who wants
to come over here and they're an asset
to the United States I'm not sure that
Ireland should have to give up anything
for that I think that you know if people
wanna go work in Ireland they should be
able to go work in Ireland that you're
gonna work visa and if they want to work
here they should come here and get a
work visa I really don't think
immigration is all that difficult an
issue I think people make it more
complicated then necessary because
they're afraid of objective standards
that they think are going to end up with
some sort of racial ethnic disparity
Isaac's is heibon I'm seventeen and over
the past couple of years I've developed
a great interest in politics mainly the
Constitution this is giving me a chance
to write some constitutional opinion
pieces from a local paper I know this is
how you got started I want to know if
you had an advice on how I should try to
get my articles published elsewhere
thanks for your concern of stand I'm a
huge fan I think well Isaac I'll say
this you know when I was seventeen and I
was writing a syndicated column one of
the things that was happening one of the
reasons that my column was picked up is
because it wasn't just my opinions it
was also me doing reportage from college
campuses so if you actually want people
to take your opinion seriously first you
have to offer something that no one else
can offer not your opinion but something
new
so either you
uncovered a fact or you have or you have
reported on something that people
haven't known before and when you do
that then people actually starts to take
your opinion a lot more seriously
because you're bringing information they
haven't heard this creates a bond of
trust between you and the reader and now
they actually want to hear what you
think about the issues that you've
brought to the forefront so you have a
phone as my mentor Andrew Breitbart said
your phone is a camera that means you're
a reporter now Logan says Haven I was
wondering what your stance on military
intervention is do you take the more
libertarian isolationist stance
or do you believe that his leader of the
free world who have a moral obligation
to involve ourselves in conflicts we
have otherwise no business and thanks
for the awesome content Logan so I think
that number one we generally should not
get involved in conflicts in which
America has no interest that said if we
can stop you know a humanitarian crisis
from occurring with very little
sacrifice of American blood and treasure
then that may be worth considering
simply because we may end up winning
allies in that place we may have Maine
and up making that country into a better
country I'm not in favor of us being
there for long periods of time in
nation-building but every I think that
muddling through is the basic principle
of American foreign policy it really is
and what that means is that you have to
take every situation as it comes and
calculate it based on a risk/reward
assessment I don't think that is
one-size-fits-all I don't think it's
like it means minimum standards now
we're gonna get involved I think you
have to look instead at what it costs
you have to look at how much money how
much blood we're gonna have to spend how
many soldiers wouldn't have to send over
there what the outcomes are going to be
case-by-case basis is necessary which
for the you know is why I was in favor
of the Iraq invasion but not in favor of
the intervention in Libya to overthrow
Qaddafi for example okay final question
Daniel says hey Ben love the show I'm
trying to find tickets for the Trump
Biden brawl was listening to you and
your bestie nosy talk about all those
shootings and bombings there's a lot of
talk about how it's mostly what young
males shoot in schools churches are
bombing I do not think it's terrorism
and it's obviously must be ideologically
motivated to be terrorism why do you
think all these young white males are
doing this shoutout from Alaska we're
freezing for no reason PS we own a lot
of guns up here no school shootings well
I think that a lot of young males are
involved in violence period right it's
just different kinds of violence
young males are the most violent cohort
in the United States it's true across
the world this is always been true for
all of world history and I think that a
lot of young white males are doing this
right now because there's a tremendous
lack of meaning that said in American
society and also they're not enough
parents in the home to provide that
meaning I think that's
it's a really simplistic solution okay
so - okay a couple more questions couple
more questions so Elise says why is it
that almost all people of the same
occupation example teachers all seem to
have the same politics well the answer
there is that in order for you that
there actually is a teacher's guild in
order for you remember the teachers
guild in many states you actually have
to be a member of the Union the union is
a leftist Union because you are a state
employee I think one of the reasons
teachers tend to swing to the left is
because state employees tend to swing to
the left because when you work for the
state you happen to think the state is
your friend this is something that
Ludwig von Mises argued in his pamphlet
/ book bureaucracy which is worth a read
another question says if you had to make
a new dollar bill who would you choose
to put on that dollar bill um Wow good
great question um well Reagan's not on a
dollar bill so I think they'd have to
you'd have to talk about putting Reagan
on a dollar bill obviously other choices
would include Calvin Coolidge I actually
was not averse to putting Harriet Tubman
on on dollar bill I think that's
actually a cool idea I'm not sure she
should entropies currently on a dollar
bill I'm not a big fan of wiping away
history in order to add new history but
I do think that if we're gonna create a
new dollar bill Harriet Tubman was a
serious badass
I mean Harriet Tubman was just awesome
and better we should put Harriet Tubman
on a dollar bill than we should you know
find a you know the dude kind of
affirmative action for women and find
somebody who wasn't as badass as Harriet
Tubman she's pretty awesome okay time
for some things I like and some things I
hate so first the actual the actual
thing I like today is a book by the end
of it called the end of Europe by Jamie
Carr check Jamie is a columnist I
believe for daily beast and this book
the end of Europe is about he traveled
around Europe and he looked at sort of
the rise of right-wing nationalism in
contrast to the collapse of the
multicultural ethos in Europe the book
is really worth reading it's a really
fascinating look at dictators demagogues
in the coming Dark Age it's very
pessimistic about the state of Europe I
tend to agree with the book you should
definitely go pick up a copy Jim's a
really really good writer and a very
solid thinker go check it out James Kern
checks the end of Europe okay so other
things that I liked so yesterday Glenn
Beck came over to the studio which is
blast and we just decided to sit down to
an impromptu interview and just talk
about stuff that was on Glenn's mind so
just for like 10 minutes we just sat and
talked about like artificial
intelligence and just fun stuff so here
is me talking with Glenn yesterday so
this is a thing I like
all right so here we are and I have the
pleasure of sitting next to Glenn Beck
one of the iconic figures in the
conservative thought movement and a
mentor of mine and somebody who I've
been listening to since I was literally
a child I have to tell you thank you for
that I was flying in and we were talking
about coming in to see you and I thought
every time Ben says he's a fan of mine
it feels so weird because I'm such a fan
of yours that's what he they informed me
that I was gonna be doing the show with
you and I'm like no no it's like you
know AI talking to an ant no no thank
you
well you know let's talk about AI
because I know that you've been very
into it we were talking a little bit
before we started about sort of the big
problems facing humanity because I think
the one of the things that we have in
common when we've talked and we're
friends is that we actually enjoy
talking about the big ideas more than we
enjoy talking about the the writing at
the tip of the iceberg really it's much
more interesting talking about the
deeper issues that are gonna be shaping
us and one of things you were mentioning
that I don't know anything about is is
you know the problems of incipient AI I
mean like I know enough to know that I'm
not supremely concerned about
self-driving cars yeah but the stuff
you're talking about it's a lot deeper
than that yeah the problem is and when
you talk about the future you people
think you're talking about robots and
the terminator and everything else you
shouldn't fear that you should fear the
goals of the programmers and the goals
of the program itself ai is what we have
now in maybe 10 years we'll have a GI
which is artificial general intelligence
which right now
you know Watson can play chess or you
can do jeopardy but it can't do
everything okay so it's it's focused on
one goal and that and it goes very deep
right artificial general intelligence is
more like the human brain where you can
do a lot of different things your expert
on a lot of every things anywhere does
that have creative capacity yeah yeah oh
and then from that point it goes from a
GI to a si and that's more of Skynet
that's described as intelligence that so
far beyond human abilities that the
human will be a fly on a plate in a
kitchen it may know that's food but it
has no concept of the kid
or anything else so so we're the fly ASI
is us in the kitchen so I mean what
should what should what exactly should
we be fearing about about that beyond
obviously the global war but but aside
from that we're in now a period where
China has begun a a GI Manhattan Project
if you will and Russia is starting to do
it we're not and I don't know I've
talked a lot of people in Silicon Valley
I don't know if the government should be
involved the government shouldn't be
involved
III don't know exactly what we should be
doing but we don't want to be second as
Putin says whoever gets it will rule the
world and that's true whoever gets to
AGI first wins so do you think that when
it comes to the development of AGI that
we're gonna be talking about more sort
of a human-machine merger when we talk
about memory implants and brain
intellectual implants I almost sort of
like 2030 you'll start to have implants
the the the singularity of merging man
and machine you know you're already
seeing bionics that you know and they
say in about three years the bionics
will be able to just think and it will
be attached and you're thinking it's
amazing yeah it's amazing
Ray Kurzweil says that by 2030 all
disease all disease will be wiped out
through nano bet none a no bot
technology etc etc so we're experiencing
this great explosion of freedom of life
that we can't even imagine but we're not
having the conversations that I think
are really important because they're too
uncomfortable they're uncomfortable for
because the labels all have to be
dropped for instance right now we're
looking at unemployment rate we're
saying it's great it's four percent but
the people who are working on on AI and
AGI are saying wait we should be going
for a hundred percent unemployment right
it's all these your time right all these
are time which then says well where do
people find meaning how
are we going to be giving people money
yep it leads to the min come kind of
conversation which I know I'm not a
supporter of the min come right but we
have to start having the conversation
because those who are shaping the world
of tomorrow are having those guns and
this this raises a second question I
think which really is the primary
question which is you know what are
human beings and what are we here to do
and that's a crisis of meaning that's
been taking place in us for a really
long time and what is life yeah but you
know if you rate if you read Ray
Kurzweil and many others we are he
believes by 2030 to 2050 that you know
you're you will not be able the Turing
test is just a few years away and when a
computer says don't turn me off I'm
lonely
is it like mmm-hmm
we can't agree on the life inside of a
woman right that's why you you have to
fear the goals of of this because it's
now being taught what life is by us
right being taught what life is it's to
be taught what hates being when you when
you have the ADL just started an
algorithm that they just announced and
they said we start an algorithm that
seventy six percent of the time will
find an identify hate speech well wait
hold it right
what is he yeah how are you defining it
what do you mean and they said in a very
short period of time we believe this
algorithm will be able to identify hate
speech 100% of the time when you teach a
a I especially AG I mean it's focused on
one goal and it doesn't ever stop mm-hm
and if it's defining hate speech and
you're Prager University
yeah you'd be screwed yeah you'll be
screwed yeah and and you know again I
think that what that returns to is
something that's that's deeper that's
going on these are questions about how
we're going to apply you know our
morality and our own virtue but that
raises the main question which is what
is morality and what is virtue and what
exactly should we be pursuing you're
saying that conversation take place
among folks like Steven Pinker who I
know you've had on your show you know
this renewed interest in enlightenment
ideology and you know I think Jordan
Peterson is great yeah I mean you
a leader in this I mean I am thrilled at
the conversation that we're having I
disagree with with pink her a lot yeah
yeah you know I think he's I think he's
so he's beyond an atheist right he is
religions about it yeah militant anti
religion and so some of his books are a
little hard to read feel like I got it
exactly you know but we have to have the
conversations and and you know you are a
prime example of this colleges are now
teaching about safe zones we have to
understand there's a difference between
feeling uncomfortable and unsafe right
right exactly
here's why Pinker is getting labeled all
right and the guy taught at Harvard I
mean I took a class with him in
Dershowitz when I was at Harvard Law and
both of those guys were now being they
were wild leftist when I was there and
they're still wild leftist what I mean
Steven Pinker is not a right winger
right he's just somebody who actually
cares about actual neuroscientific fact
this and it's in he's being labeled this
way modernism but the nice thing is that
the left's in the left's moved to the
radical left their their radicalization
has meant that there is this sort of new
consensus that is arising that we have
to get back to some of these central
values the big question is gonna be how
far back do we go meaning that Steven
Pinker sort of wants to turn back the
clock to 1785 in terms of enlightenment
thought and says that this sort of
thought is is the is the future right if
we go back to the general principles of
the American enlightenment for example
sort of ignores Rousseau but if you go
back to that strain of the Enlightenment
then we're great then you see the same
thing in general Goldberg's new book he
sort of uses those same people as the
examples of the people who we should be
looking back to and I think there's
actually interesting debate Jordan and I
both say well you have to actually look
if you're looking for meaning you can't
start with the Enlightenment no you have
to actually go back further than the
Enlightenment and look back to the roots
of what caused the Enlightenment to
arise in the first place and that's
abate I think is gonna be it's a second
order to make but I think in some ways
it's a deeper debate that's gonna be
happy if you don't do that you end up
with a French Revolution right this is
essential matter I mean I mean this is
my big problem with Pinker's book is
it's 500 pages on the Enlightenment and
there's no I mean I check the index
there's not one mention of the French
Revolution in a 500 page book about Hale
and what's amazing is Thomas Jefferson
Thomas Paine were fooled by that right
they were fooled by because it's what
we're going through right now at the
very beginning it looks the same well in
an end and all the way to I have people
telling me what's wrong with nationalism
I'm proud of my country right no no no
that's Patriots but right but they but
there's that Sun at the very beating
there's that subtle shift and then
before you know is exactly the
guillotine or you're in Philadelphia
right exactly this is exactly right I
mean there is a butterfly effect to
philosophy and if there's these minor
differences and of having major
variations they caused tsunamis in world
history yeah based on the difference
between american-style exceptionalism
and fect style german romantic
nationalism right and one leads to the
Nazis and one leads to the people
fighting the Nazis and so it's it's a
fascinating debate it's one that's gonna
have to be had again because there was a
certain consensus that built up to the
1950s that the American Enlightenment
was the way to go that these values had
been ensconced in our lives and now that
consensus seems to have completely
disappeared and so these fights are
breaking out again the good news is that
the fight is allowing the re-education
of a lot of folks not like what I'm
gonna style reeducation but like the
orientation of values that are an
important and necessary I remember oh oh
twenty years ago reading Marx and just
thinking this is crazy right and
thinking this is only cool because
everybody says it's not cool it's not
good I shouldn't read it and I thought
someday maybe Jefferson who's a real
thinker mmm-hmm you know Jefferson and
and and Adams and Madison someday
they'll become cool again mm-hmm I think
we're at the beginning of it I think
that's right I think the American
Founding is is is becoming cool again
and I think that it's this is gonna be
the battle is gonna be rejoined because
we're we're going to keep repeating the
mistakes of the Enlightenment and
counter enlightenment until we get it
right so maybe this time we actually get
it right and a post god rule that's the
only battle that can be had we're just
gonna keep repeating it until things
either go ultimately wrong or ultimately
right and I I am shocked and and and
happy to see I think a lot of it is
happening in the one place I wouldn't
expect and that's California yeah you
know Texas not having this debate you
know they've they're solid on you know
pretty
we'll have it that's right after
California moves to Texas okay and all
the property values Gladys here there's
nobody left but they'll have it once
they destroy Texas but if they're not
having that deep debate here there's a
crisis and and people are starting to
have that that conversation yes
important crisis definitely generates
some interesting ideas and in debates
that need to be had
well Glen thanks so much for stopping by
and it's always great to see you thank
you so so blessed to have Glen in studio
so obviously we've had some pretty big
guests recently we had two speaker Ryan
this week we have Glen this week next
week I believe senator Cruz is gonna be
coming on and Thomas soul is coming on
so it's been fun to do some of these
interviews I like putting them in the
thing is I like segments so we can do
all the news analysis first and then
folks can get a little bit of different
perspective in conversation a little bit
later in the show so I like your
feedback on that by the way email me at
B Shapiro daily wire and tell me if
you've been enjoying the interviews or
if you think they suck but I'm really
enjoying them I think they're fun okay
so time for a very quick thing I hate
and then we will break for the weekend
because it's Friday fret no I will not
sing that okay so time for some things I
hate alrighty so thing that I hate
number one a guy is now facing jail time
for making an offensive joke in Britain
was his offensive joke his pug that does
a Nazi salute like his dog does a Nazi
salute he's now facing jail time for it
this weirdo was just most of the fact I
was like I know why I made the joke you
know why I made the joke everybody knows
why I made the dog what my intent was
and also the context that was provided
and what we learn today is that doesn't
Marv it's just there it's really scary
for comedians Leo comedians oh the
alternative but we all know if they make
a joke their context and intent are
partly don't ma and it's a case of no
you don't get to decide what you mean we
decide what you mean because I said left
only what happened today see if it takes
me going into for a year to show
everyone how ridiculous and overreaching
hate speech laws are well a YouTube
comedian just done a post on like myself
can go a present for an entire year if
that's what it would take for everyone
in the country I realize all these laws
and he changed the overreach in that
authoritarian that clearly been used to
control the public discourse
okay so here's what he actually did
right now what he's saying here is
actually right the guy's an idiot so he
actually what he actually
he taught his dog to did to do the Nazi
salute every time he said stuff like
Sieg Heil and gas the Jews okay so he
may be like a POS right he may be like a
bad guy but welcome to the Western world
where you're allowed to say nasty things
so long as you don't actually do
anything nasty I'm defending this as an
Orthodox Jew not the activity but the
right to participate in the sort of
activity if we can't agree on that then
freedom disappears pretty pretty quickly
okay one final thing that I hate and
then we will break through weekend
president Trump did a did an interview
with Charlie Kirk Charlie of course the
head of TP USA which is a terrific
organization Charlie's a really great
guy and and Charlie asked President
Trump about bias against conservatives
on college campuses and Trump gives an
answer that is pretty inane what advice
do you have for young patriots and
conservatives on campus that support
your agenda that are being ridiculed and
silenced because of administrators that
are clamping down on free speech so
surely it's a great question I think the
numbers are actually much different than
people think I think we have a lot of
support if they have one campus or two
campuses and we know what they are it
gets all the publicity we have campuses
where you have a vast majority of people
that are perhaps like many of the people
in this room you could call it
conservative you call it whatever you
want
okay so Trump basically saying it's not
a big deal what's happening on the
campuses which is not the answer that
Charlie was looking for nor is it
correct now no one is claiming that
campuses everywhere are shutting down
conservative speakers I speak on a lot
of campuses all the time do they put
restrictions they wouldn't put on a
lefty speaker sure but I've never
claimed that every campus I go to is a
hotbed of disaster waiting to happen in
fact I always think it's ridiculous I
even have to bring security to go speak
on campuses I will say that there is a
well an overwhelming bias in the
administration's of universities across
the country and in the faculty against
Republican positions and polls show this
so Trump is just wrong about this I
think Trump read the question wrong
wouldn't Charlie asked him what students
should do when they're under assault on
campus I think Trump read that as
everybody on campus loves me because
everybody loves me
which is of course silly because if you
take polls of college students that is
not the case and conservatives on campus
who I talk to every single day are
having a tough time dealing with the
political bias on campus okay we'll be
back here on Monday and I'm sure
there'll be more news breaking because
there always is don't ruin things over
the week
just have a nice relaxed weekend I'll be
back around Monday to ruin your life
again at that point I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and arrow
audios mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018